And as you walk through, you could
see that there was a big shipping
container at the back within the workshop.
You always look at every aspect of
their life.
So you look at where they live,
where they frequent, where they work.
So his workplace came to light as
a potential area for investigation.
It just destroys DNA.
You've got to have a significant amount
of bone to be able to preserve
the DNA within it, to be able
to get DNA.
I need to try it.
So we picked the biggest seven pieces
of bone to see whether we could
obtain DNA.
They tried.
They couldn't get anything.
We were never going to be able
to prove that bone was definitively Alex's
by DNA.
It's frustrating.